[Music]
so good afternoon everybody it's great
to see so many faces today we'll talk
about what's the uncertainty on your
machine learning predictions but before
we go into that let's give a brief
introduction about ourselves so this is
fabian eunsu my name is a 15 wheel or
two data scientist working at ING and
we're trying really hard not to be too
much of a banger so bear with us so say
you're throwing a dinner party right and
you're expecting about 10 guests then it
could be the case that on the day that
you're actually throwing a party there's
some more some less right however it's
kind of important to know how many more
or less say you're doing grocery
shopping and it's just one person more
or less or six out of ten so in this
case uncertainty you really matters you
really want to know it's going to be one
more or six more so then speaking of
this uncertainty we're trying to build
our own package in Python and to our
knowledge we've not found another one
that does it in a similar way so we
thought okay we think it's very
important to show these entities with
your prediction so let's build our own
so when I'm talking about uncertainty
and errors what is it that I actually
mean so for us we're looking at how far
could we be off in our predictions so as
data scientists are trying to make
models right to give predictions so it's
also important to realize how far could
we all be off so what's the uncertainty
or error in each of the predictions that
we make so they're actually two types of
uncertainty first one they call
systematic uncertainties and these are
related to for example the type of model
that you that you use to try to solve
your problem or whether you have missing
data that turns out to be very important
for the problem you're trying to solve
but you just don't have it at hand today
I will not talk about those actually
we'll talk about the second type of
uncertainty which
just got statistical uncertainty and
they come from the fact that we have
limited training data for example so
let's start with an example to get a bit
of feel about this so say we are
creating a data set according to a non
sigmoid probability distribution so we
know we have a slope of 4 and we have a
bias of zero and we're just generating
in this example 100 data points so if we
try to fit a logistic regression to this
and try to get back this exact same
curve we'll probably find a slightly
different slope and bias in this case
it's four point seven and zero point one
well it kind of makes sense right
because we only looked at 100 data
points so we're kind of likely to not
exactly find that slope that we knew
beforehand and the bias that came with a
distribution how we defined it so if
would have had a different data set
probably again the bias and the slope
would have been slightly different so
what if we repeat this example a
thousand times so we generate thousand
different data sets and we fit a
logistic regression to each of those
data sets we'll get something like this
so we'll get a distribution for the
slopes that we could have fitted for
this distribution and bias and in orange
you actually see all the curves that we
fit it around the black one that's the
one that we know with a slope of 4 and a
bias of 0 and as you can see nicely here
there's kind of a lot of space around
the exact function that we're trying to
fit right so this is sort of already
showing the type of uncertainty that we
have by limited amount of data so yeah
well that's basically what I just said
so how do we then estimate these
uncertainties right because you read or
not just do this a thousand times every
time and then make error bands like this
so we have two steps so the first one is
we need to estimate the uncertainty in
the model parameters that we actually
have
and once you've calculated in certainty
over these parameters we actually need
to propagate those uncertainties onto
our into individual predictions
so now let's get away of the theoretical
kind of an example and let's look at a
real data set maybe most of you already
know it but there's a data set about the
probability of surviving the Titanic so
we'll look into that one today
so in this data set you have all kind of
information about the passengers on
board say the fare they paid to get onto
the ship what class they were into first
second or third class where there was a
man or a woman what was their age and we
try to predict what is their probability
of survival for the Titanic so often
this data scientists we start by looking
at some data distributions and we try to
get a feel for these features say at a
class for example that they were the
ship on what does that tell us about the
probability of survival right even
before we try to fit the model and we
see something interesting here so in
orange we see all the passengers and in
green we see the people that survived
and it seems that women in the status
set for example survived more often
whereas people who pay dirt for
third-class get not so we already get a
little bit of a feel what's going on
with the data but we don't know yet
what's the uncertainty over these
parameters right so we train a model
we've selected all these features like
gender what they paid and we have one
target do rotation five yes or no we
split our data on the Train and a test
set so that we know for certain that
performance that we measure is some
independent data set of which the model
has never seen any data and then we use
her own package we call it error tools
and we use her logistic regression
implementation to fit the model and we
find these parameter values so okay so
now that we train the model we're ready
to
get the insert these on the parameters
so a little bit back to theory so on how
we actually do it let's say behind the
scenes when we train a model when we fit
a model we're actually often most models
we're minimizing a loss function right
and it's kind of important to realize
that when you minimize a loss function
implicitly you're also maximizing
likelihood and this is something that we
use in an estimation of our
uncertainties okay so when you train a
model you have model parameters the bias
and the slope of the earlier one and
these are the ones that minimize the
loss function as you see in the picture
below at the same time these are the
parameters that actually maximize the
likelihood as you see in the picture on
the right so these are the optimal
parameters in this sense that doesn't
mean that other parameters are not
likely I mean we could actually if you
look at the likelihood we could just go
a little bit to the left or a little bit
to the right and it's still quite likely
it's kind of like saying like if I had a
different data set and I might end up
just a bit to the right just a bit to
the left
so it's still very likely so for us the
task to estimate the uncertainty is
basically saying okay what's the range
left right that we still consider likely
enough so that's what we'll do to do
this we make in our code we actually
make an approximation we make a
parabolic approximation of a loss
function basically saying that you
approximate your loss function as a
multivariate parabola there's there's a
little benefit for the likelihood but
because it turns likelihood into a to a
Gaussian into a normal distribution
multivariate normal distribution and
this actually has a nice benefit because
the the model the errors actually they
roll right out because normal
distribution multivariate it has a
covariance matrix and the covariance
matrix actually has all the information
that we need because on the diagonal of
this matrix you find the
errors on the parameters and actually
peripherally the off-diagonal they
contained correlations between the
parameters if you're interested in those
two so we can apply this we have
implemented this and you can ask our
model what are the errors on the
parameters and you see them here at the
bottom for convenience we have also made
a reporting function with which you can
visualize these parameters and it's kind
of interesting to see so here you see
the all the features and their
parameters and their uncertainties in
one plot you see that fair it has a
large value so the amount of money you
pay to get on port the ship actually has
a very large parameter so you might
think this is a very important feature
however it also has a large uncertainty
so in claiming that this is important
you're actually not very sure however if
you go if you look at sex or what are
your male or female it has a fairly
large value but it has a tiny
uncertainty so in claiming that this is
this feature is important you're
actually quite sure I just told you so
we make an approximation of our last
function to determine our uncertainties
on our parameters so how good this
approximation is it also determines how
good our estimates of our parameters are
if this is a bad approximation we can
trust the error estimates so for this
bird we have also made a reporting
function with which you can visualize
this and you see in a example and you
know in this case you actually see that
the parabolic approximation and the
original they are very close so this is
actually good approximation which means
that it's fairly okay to trust your
uncertainty estimates so now that we
have the uncertainty estimates on our
models parameters we can actually use
these to also make uncertainties on our
predictions so for this a prediction it
basically it's a function it's a
function that takes as inputs your
features and the parameters of your
model
so to make the prediction we just use
the model parameters that we trained on
so let's say the optimal ones so these
are values like always like you did
always with which you make the
prediction and we use the uncertainties
that we got on the model parameters to
propagate these to insert these on our
predictions now there's not one way to
do this or actually several ways with
which you can do this I just like to
highlight two they all have benefits
they have drawbacks just two that we
have implemented we've actually
implemented more but two that are kind
of intuitive at least the second one the
first one is I named it because it's
it's kind of a common technique to
estimate quickly estimate uncertainties
on your prediction it's called linear
error propagation and it's interesting
because you don't have to iterate you
don't have to sample it's just one
calculation one equation and it gives
you a very fast estimate however it uses
an approximation of its own so in some
cases it may be in exact and then of
course there is the hammer to anything
that looks like a nail just sample so in
this case we sample parameter values
from the gaussian likelihood that we
have and by sampling different parameter
values you use these to make predictions
you also vary your prediction and you
look at the variation and as basically
your error so this one of course gets
more accurate if you sample more but it
also gets lower so let's apply these to
our test set so we trained our model
right so now next step is we want to
make these predictions and visualize
these uncertainties that that just
explaining the theory behind so of
course we like in a scalar and for
example we made a predict function in
our error tools and we can give it some
test part of the test set that we set
apart in the beginning of you remember
and we'll get the probability of
surviving the Titanic for these data
samples now we can also request from the
model to give us the
on these predictions indicating which
type of error propagation method you
would like to use so in this example we
use the linear error propagation but
here you could also indicate for example
that you would like to use the sampling
one slightly slower but maybe more
accurate however what might be more
interesting is to actually visualize
these error rates because if you just
look at lists of numbers of
uncertainties that might not tell us too
much if we have a big test set so what
we did here is we're showing all the
touch samples on the x-axis ordered by
their probability of surviving the
titanic from high to low and in green
you see all the test samples that were
labeled as yes survived a titanic and
the red ones are actually the ones that
did not survive the titanic one very
intriguing thing that i think that we
can see here in this image is that we
have someone someone's here more on the
left they are red so in between the ones
where the model actually sets we have
high probability of surviving the
titanic we actually see that there's
large uncertainty on those test samples
so we could get an intuitive feel about
the game the models saying they are
surviving but there's a large concern
that the overdose didn't survive in the
end there and exactly we made something
else next to that because maybe you do
not want to look at your test set as a
whole right maybe you would also like to
make a prediction curse because if we
look at real-life data science problems
that maybe you and I try to solve it's
quite common to make decisions on one
single prediction so for example I don't
know for the people that were the talk
of hater this morning at back mat they
have a doctor makes a decision to
dismiss a patient based on one number
right so it's important we can actually
say something about uncertainty on
individual predictions so that's why we
also made the reporting functionality
for deaths so let's take an example say
we have somebody like five
he's 42 years old it's a meal he happy
to book a ticket in the third class and
he went aboard with no family so let's
visualize what is his probability of
winning as a function of the fare that
he will pay to get aboard so if we look
at this function it might seem that the
more he pays keep in mind is a scaled
version of the data so if a scaled
version of fare
the more he pays the more likely he is
to survive well I'll just pay a lot pay
a lot right if that will be the case and
we'll just pay a lot and we hope we
survive but are we actually so sure that
paying more or actually later surviving
the Titanic right maybe not let's look
at the uncertainty of this individual
prediction we see it here so actually we
see that paying more indeed in the curve
might lead to higher probability of
surviving however the uncertainty also
is growing a lot so in fact his
probability of survival could have been
anywhere here as well right we're pretty
uncertain for this specific situation
I'm not getting on that boat should not
get on the boat so next to that this
uncertainty issue not only propagates to
the predictions that we make but they
also propagate to the metrics that we
use to determine how well our model is
performing so things like precision
recall a you see they're all impacted by
this uncertainties that we have because
of limited training data so let's look
at the AUC and we see for example that
for the model that we train we have an
AUC of 0.8 4 which in itself is pretty
okay it's pretty high but it's important
to also keep in mind what is the
uncertainty over this score right
because say your models being used in a
production environment then it's
important that the people that actually
use this know what are the uncertainties
that your model actually has so below we
see an ROC and we're
ashle giving the uncertainty here on the
true positive rate so in this direction
you could of course also calculate the
uncertainty in the other direction but
it's a little bit less interpretable I
would say so keep in mind it does not
only propagate to your predictions but
also to the metrics that you're actually
showing about the model that you build
so to recap we're not only creating a
package chimp item that you could use to
train models but we're also providing to
you a way to estimate uncertainties on
these predictions and on top of that
we've made some reporting visualizations
that can help you to interpret these
uncertainties of the predictions that
you make but what's next because we're
really far from done we started I think
about two or three months ago mainly so
if you don't adjusting now please have a
look at our github code but bear with us
because we need to reflect there's still
a lot of things and most likely over
time things will change and there are a
lot of other things that we would like
to still get implemented so first up we
need to put it on pi PI because and at
least it's easily installable we'd like
to include other performance metrics
like the confusion matrix because there
as well you will get the propagation of
this uncertainty of your model we would
like to integrate includes an option
that you provide an already trained
model to our package and we'll just give
back to you the uncertainties on the
model that you already trained it's
important to keep in mind it what type
of model and of course you're providing
because the parabolic approximation that
we were showing in this case it holds
for functions that are actually
minimizing a loss so if you would like
to do different models like for example
tree based models we need to come up
with a slightly different way of
calculating these approximations so it's
not usable for all type of models now
which leads to also may be an obvious
follow-up question can we do this for
neural Nets we believe so but it's not
implemented yet we may just start with
PI torch that there is more work to be
done
so if you'd like to contribute also let
us know of course and one more thing
that we're thinking about is now we
looked at the classification problem
right but a lot of problems in data
science might be more of the regression
type you would like also to include our
estimations for regressors like
chi-squared filters for example so
that's it thanks a lot
[Applause]